um just a minute mother one minute
all the secrets away secrets mrs. Walsh
just called wants to know through the
baby sit for it a night yeah I can I'll
call right back
provided you do your homework first I
will
you
Oh
woe betide any an iced person who reads
the private contents of Norma Davis
there is no question about it
my legs grew longer in the last two
weeks
seems to me the whole world is changing
well last year there were woods in
Douglas Park and now it's all houses and
there's hardly a tree left Lucile and
Wendy and I went out of our way this
afternoon just to see what Dutton's park
looks like now up close
Lucile says I was very embarrassing to
her the way I looked at everything
Thursday spent the afternoon with Jack
Ryan graphed many cups of hot chocolate
yr old boys named John call Jack how is
it you know somebody a long time then oh
you realize how nice they are
I drank as much hot chocolate as I could
but everything has to come to an end
yeah she got their diary then Frank
alaya Oh diaries kind of fascinating
I keep a diary you know yours oh I
didn't mean
thanks jack it's okay
you're my gray
sometimes
me too sometimes it's real nice all
right Sleeping Beauty wake up Supper's
on I'm not sleeping I'm reading when did
you become a bookworm look Gus - how
many times do I have to tell you not to
come into my room without knocking look
if you want so much privacy
get yourself a doorman Supper's on the
table I where would you want anything
down around here you have to do with
yourself Norma Norma supper I'm coming
and something new you finish with your
soup Norma I'm just wondering what it
would take to get that much of your
attention have you read it daddy no but
I've heard of it it's supposed to be
true it's about this little girl and
Frank and her family and they live in
Holland they're Jews end up they have to
go into hiding it into this attic
because the Nazis want to find them and
put them into a concentration camp just
because they're Jewish they didn't do
anything is that really true it happened
what how could people let a thing like
that happen why didn't they do something
we did all the people in tetons pocket
Jews what's that supposed to mean
nothing just repeating chitchat well if
my family doesn't mind I think I'd like
to change the subject daddy can I have
my book back
after supper how things go today they
all right Oh Vance Miller made by a
whole new heating system using the store
this morning trying to get me to talk
him out of it
gonna be a big job that comes through
yes okay Norman for what it's worth the
war's over the Nazis have finished this
kind of thing doesn't happen anymore so
the best thing to do is forget about it
and it's your dinner brother Oh Jack
Ryan asked me to go to Alice Owens party
Saturday night
well could I do some my silly money and
buy a new dress what does he wanna you
want me to shop with you who would you
shoot love and marriage love and
marriage love come on cut it out will
you
back to normal yeah mother is that gonna
be too short no they're wearing them
short now
you like oh it's dreamy how come on
can't wear a dress like that how come I
always get stuck with those silly frilly
things out out this minute your time is
yet to come I got rid of her okay
Wendy and I slept at Lucille's house
last night
I think mrs. Draper is swell next to my
own mother
mrs. Draper is my idea of the kind of
mother to have
here we are Lucille and Wendy and I the
inseparable three oh I feel so wonderful
friendship is the best thing in the
world will they be my friends when I'm
50 only 11 more days to my birthday this
is the best birthday of all in the whole
world
a pearl necklace for mother and daddy
and crazy Augusta got me a genuine
silver bracelet Guster where did you get
it in a jewelry store I'm at the cost a
fortune where'd you get the money well I
had five dollars saved up and I went
into the store on Henry Street where
they sell all those watches and he had
this bracelet somebody left it there to
have it creamed they gave it to me for
what it cost to have it cleaned cost me
a dollar 50 I got this pin for myself
what's the riding on this charm is it
Arabic well I don't know he said he'd
have another one to go with it in the
drop-in he'd give it to you Oh daddy
what is this Arabic or Turkish oh I
think it's Hebrew it may be Arabic
I knew I find it somewhere that's a
Jewish star I thought you said it was
Arabic I thought it was Arabic is it
Jewish it's a Jewish bracelet the stars
for good luck this is a mezuzah the
words mean that thou shalt love the Lord
thy God with all thy heart and with all
my soul
words here explain that there's one God
and He is God shall I attach the John
yes please are you crazy
what's the matter what's the matter it's
a Jewish star he told you so would you
like something else instead
no thank you you change your mind I'd be
glad to give you something else thank
you this is what I want
bye-bye are you actually gonna wear that
thing sure he couldn't get me to wear it
you're not me look here no one thought
there was anything wrong with this
bracelet before when we thought it was
Arabic for something it's different you
were that Spanish coin bracelet all the
time why shouldn't I wear this one I
don't care Norman don't think I care
it's just that people are going to think
it's very peculiar that's all Spanish
isn't Jewish if somebody who was Jewish
wanted to wear it it would be fun I
think the Jews are going to object it
doesn't have anything to do with the Jew
will you please tell me what it does
have to do it because I don't understand
what you're talking about well nobody
has to explain things like that you just
know them everybody knows what I'm not
going to stand here arguing about it in
front of him
it's my bracelet and I don't care who
thinks what about it it's so stupid and
prejudiced and it makes me mad to think
that the only thing my very best friends
care about is what other people are
going to think you can't let other
people think for you you have to think
for yourself otherwise you might just as
well be in prison my bracelet has become
very celebrated Jack and I were ice
skating and Lucille was pretending to be
a good friend
she went to Jack and told him I was
making a fool of myself
so Jack told me I will not take it off
goose is prasada I have to go ride home
me too anybody for soda I have to go to
the library
I guess it's just not a sore today
I know
I'll talk
I am guess I should have minded my own
business I shouldn't have lost my temper
I wasn't trying to tell you what to do
yes well you know you can say what you
want to just don't say it out loud
that's all I was just worried about you
what was that her worried about well uh
just have to keep something to yourself
well why why should you have to keep
anything to yourself I don't know why
everybody just done jack I could
understand if it was something junky
that made me look cheap or something but
it's just a bracelet I don't want to
argue with you Norma I've been missing
how long has this been going on this is
I got the bracelet dead I don't know
what to do
you're not really studying are you no I
was talking to your mother
I noticed it myself but we feel the same
way about it we thought I ought to talk
to you Gustus says Lucille's having a
party and you weren't invited to it you
two have a fight
I thought you two were pretty close
friends look I'm not trying to pry honey
it bothers me to see you unhappy I don't
want you to get the idea you're alone if
you're unhappy oh I know you have to
wear this bracelet every day that's
what's all about isn't it
I'm not going to be pushed by anybody
all right I don't try to tell anyone
else what to do you think it's worth
being left out of things I can't help it
all right now hon listen fathers and
mothers try and keep troubles away from
their kids if there are harsh things in
the world they try to guard them from
the harsh things I guess no one can do
that for anyone else people have to find
their own way they have to face hurt as
well as good things I don't have any
answers I can give you that are going to
solve your problems not in this case but
the fact is you could make things a lot
easier for yourself if you gave in went
along with the crowd you could put that
bracelet away for one
is that what do you want me to do no one
I'm not going to tell you what to do I
want to I'm not going to you figure
things out for yourself
whichever way you figure it your mother
and I are behind you hello mrs. Jake er
yes Norma isn't it still home yet
no she's not well we've been having a
terrible argument of some kind
well could I wait for her I have to talk
to her about it
yes Norma I think you better come in I
have something to say to you
about the bracelet yes
Norma I told Lucille she's not to invite
you to this house ever again
and she's not to go to your house I told
her to tell you but I guess she's too
embarrassed
I don't think she realizes that not
telling you is far crueler why Oh what
did I do
Norma you came into this house under
false pretenses you pretended to be
something and you aren't now that's not
honest and it's not nice and I don't
want Lucille to be friends with someone
who pretends to be something they aren't
what am I wish you wouldn't try to
embarrass me this way I don't know what
you mean I just don't know really I
don't know I'm talking about the fact
that you're Jewish I'm not Jewish Norma
I like you very much but you're behaving
very badly now and you're far too
intelligent not to know what you're
doing I understand your reasons you and
your family were you're alone in this
town a long time you felt isolated
now that Dutton's Park is built up you
have enough of your own kind is jafer
don't all feel isolated anymore you
don't feel you have to hide anymore but
why you live because you are no sale or
friends that it won't make so much of a
difference if we know now it it does
make a difference dear now I don't want
to be cruel Norma but realistically you
must make friends among your own kind do
you understand me now dear and you must
understand I I have to protect Lucille I
want you to understand my position this
is very difficult for me
the wall over this kind of thing doesn't
happen so the best thing to do is forget
about it I'm not going to tell you what
to do I want to I'm not going you figure
things out for yourself
whichever way you figure it your mother
and I are behind you
maybe everyone many come to order please
tonight we have a surprise speaker some
time ago I received a visitor in my
office the young lady who was brought to
me by a teacher
this young lady brought with her a diary
and she allowed me to read certain
portions of it and I must say I was
shocked by what I read there she raises
the question which is of great
importance so I've asked her to read her
diary to us and she agreed I present to
you miss Norma Davis
the only two people who ever saw my
diary before are my teacher mr. Carter
and mr. Clark the principal but I
thought that I should read some of it to
you because some things have happened to
me and the best way to tell them is the
way I have them put down for myself if
anyone had ever told me that these
things could happen to me really I
wouldn't have believed them so I don't
know if you'll believe me but I think
this is important to think about because
you don't get rid of things just by not
thinking about them you have to do
something about them the main thing is
that young people like myself are
growing up very fast and pretty soon
we'll be grown up and this will be our
world and it'll be what we make it and
whatever will be is whatever shape were
made into by our parents and so we have
to worry about the world and our parents
have to worry about us and well I don't
know maybe when you hear what's written
in my diary maybe you'll think it's it's
fine and that's the way things ought to
be but I think it's not fine oh hi
everybody and really I'm not that
important but I just have to hope that
I'm right and it whatever happened
nobody really thought about it anyhow
you have to make up your own mind it
begins with my birthday this is the best
birthday of all baselet
it's so stupid and prejudiced and it
makes me mad to think that the only
thing my very best friends care about is
what other people are going to think you
can't let other people think for you
I feel so badly about Lucille and Wendy
we don't fight or anything but we're
just not good friends anymore
and it's not just my imagination it's
real why don't I just throw this
bracelet away oh these pages are just
personal things Jack had to stay late
for football practice and I was alone I
tried to find somebody to have a soda
with but nobody would even sit down and
drink an ice cream soda with me it isn't
just for Ceylon when they either it
everybody
I told her I wasn't Jewish she must have
heard me but I don't see how she could
have because she just went right on with
her ideas as if I'd never said a word
and when I left she told me that it was
very difficult for her I really think
she expects me to feel sorry for her I
can't figure anything else I'm so
confused
this is so much more than I can figure
out it's all arranged I have to read
your diary in front of everybody I hope
I don't hurt mother and daddy or
embarrass them or make them ashamed
I I don't mean to be defiant or anything
but I would like everybody to know that
I'm going to keep on wearing my bracelet
always
the town is everybody which is a lot of
people all acting their own way
everybody doesn't change but one by one
people do some change more into what
they were and some are ashamed to be the
way they were and their pride is hurt if
I hurt anyone's pride I didn't do it out
of meanness I'm sure of that and if I
pleaded for more understanding I didn't
do it either because I'm a friend of the
Jews it's not that I'm just not an enemy
of anybody